short question in the room, is
there anyone who only speaks English,
should we do the whole thing in English,
okay, because we are being prepared,
but then we might do it again in
German
for an update, so
I'm Theresa, we can also
use the first-name terms  Teresa Riedels have but I
come from Fraunhofer IPK have a very
large team with all the
experts Experts from the various
departments from the project
we’ll introduce ourselves again
now we still have 5 minutes that means the
second person is just being scanned to see what’s
happening  I'll give you a little
impression there, that means it's the
demonstrator that we brought with us,
it was at the
Hannover Messe this year, it's allowed to
travel to Brussels again this year, we'll show you
how I do an
individualized product,
no problem like me  can create an
individualized product
based on a scan that
means this individualized topic we are
now looking at a hand as an example
make an individualized orthosis based on the scan of
the hand,
for example, or other products which
are then planned in 3D that means the
geometric  The model is created and
based on this model the 3D is
printed. The 3D printer is actually
one of the core elements of our
project because we deal with
how to
make 3D printable material from waste materials and
then convert this into a product or convert a 3D
printed product into something  then it
is 100% biodegradable again, which
means it is compostable, you can imagine,
tell me a
bit more about that later, here we have
set it up as a demonstration,
simply so that you
can see the entire process chain, because these
are very practical examples
Not all products should
decompose again, but there are examples in
production but also privately where it is
worth
decomposing again, so for
example the orthosis is
actually an example from our
partner Mercedes-Benz, with whom we also
work, who use it for
example in the assembly, so
support or just
recognizing topics how often do I click a
certain assembly process
and of course there are a lot of
examples of a private nature we are
now coming from production so
I will always pack these production examples
but something like spare parts is
possible  what is broken in the short term in
production is the worst thing for a
production company when the production is at a
standstill that means you
can use this opportunity to
print something relatively quickly it's
about workpiece holders it's about
small parts that you use, for example,
to hold something together but
tools too, for example that's exactly what
we brought along second person is now
in the scan that means while we're
giving the presentation we can
wait quite a bit until the printed
parts are ready
quick look at the clock Sebastian have
the time for me again
43 okay  then we'll wait a bit until
the scanning team is ready and
then we'll start the presentation as
I said it'll be recorded I'd
say it again right now, even
if we're still a small group
means for everyone who's somehow involved in the
This camera is pictured here and I think
the camera is also drawn on
just be aware that there will be video
material afterwards
I would say
okay great then I would start again
I will do the query again because we have
got new visitors again
just speaks English and no German
American do the in English it was
okay great then we'll do the whole thing in
German welcome again I'll
briefly introduce myself to Teresa
my name Teresa riedershammer I come
from Fraunhofer IPK and heads the
Sustainable Product Ecosystems department there
and today we still have a relatively large
team from Fraunhofer IPK with us
who come from various
expert disciplines from the
project that is a very
interdisciplinary project takes care
of production that means we come
from the bio-fusion 4.0 project
is funded by the BMW F  the
Federal Ministry of Education and
Research and this is a very
interdisciplinary project in the context of
production, which means we take care of
everything that concerns discrete manufacturing and
productions, but we have
different expertise and
experts, which means that we are very
happy to answer any questions
Do you approach us or do you approach
us again briefly afterwards?
This will be recorded, i.e. if
someone does not want to appear on
a video, the cameras will
record the whole thing,
briefly on the agenda, we will now start
out with 20 minutes
report from the project what do we
actually do, what does
biological transformation mean, and then
we brought two demonstrators
with us to see
and learn a bit what it looks like in
practice, the experts will
also be available to answer questions  for
discussions, because to be
honest we are very much looking forward to the impulse to
bring in new ideas.
As a research project, we
naturally want to communicate our findings to the outside world,
but we also want to learn
and understand what kind of impulses there might
be for new ideas, and that's what
we want here today  on the world science path
also doing together
exactly these are the three principles
biological transformation means for
us how can production
learn from nature that is the first point of the
topic bio-inspiration that means nature
that has also been the way we are for a very, very long time
here is an inspiration for
us humans to
implement this one very classic example of the
shingansen train we have now
taken the wing shape of airplanes here
so nature has
always known relatively well whether animals or plants
can solve problems and how that is
one of the ideas  that the production
companies learn from it how to
solve problems faster and better
the second element where the
biological transformation is
developing is very, very exciting that
is the topic of integration that also means
the possibility of integrating growing materials with
moving living materials
into products  but there
are also good examples in production, for
example, mushrooms mushrooms that
grow in a certain shape, are then dried
and then produce a product. Of
course, we also
brought an example with us today and the last one
is the topic of bio-interaction, we
now have it here  Mushroom as an example Mushrooms
Trees that use spores and other
substances to communicate with each other so-
called messenger substances and you can also
learn from them that means the topic of
decentralization and intelligence
swarm intelligence also as an example of how
fish
talk to each other or communicate
we all know that you can do that in  the
production gets that means that you do
n't always have to think ahead and plan everything
and that you can react to
changing circumstances and in this
context our project
[music] moves
that we have now translated that is
now the foil that the project once
like  on the three
levels that means we are looking
at a lighthouse project in Berlin that means the
top level is the macroeconomic
system we have now called Berlin
it's about how
companies interact with each other how does that look on
the
from the whole higher level, really
e.g
or
technologies in a process, we see
on the left there was the
Bio Intelligence study by women only,
which practically
formed a bit of the basis for it
or offers the basis where does it
all come from what possibilities are
there which technologies  has created a very
nice framework framework
that we are implementing
the lighthouse project in this project, so to speak,
how do we implement that we are here
today as Fraunhofer, but we are
not alone at all, so we have a
total of 13 partners, the TU Berlin,
for example, is still involved  from
science we also have a lot of
partners from the application below
you can see the logos who work
together with Mercedes-Benz the
Marienfelde plant here in Berlin who produce the
components for the automotive industry
we work together with
budapec-clarification both
companies are automation technology
Companies and machine builders Aarburg
and Colin are two companies that
we can tell you about later.
You can prepare materials for this process chain.
We also work with
technology providers. That means context
software green dead for Delta Model
works or solid industry are everything
companies that
have different software offers, for example, but also the
topic of sustainability analysis is a
very, very important part of what we
do that is not only better and
faster is more efficient and economical
but only one task in the project is
that we want to prove it or
at least make it measurable  What do
these environmental effects
actually bring about with the technologies? That's why
we also look at the whole thing very closely with the
life cycle assessment
and then on the right we see
well-behaved because there is a company here in
Berlin that takes care of the
disposal of electrical parts but
cooking fats and so on, so really
a recycling company and  The
Werner von Siemens Zeit Santa for
Industrien science is also based in Berlin,
which is
no problem
former Siemens
AG with whom we work
together in the middle you can see
the three seven solutions that
means we have individual technological
solutions that we implement that's what I meant
with the topic of
interdisciplinarity that means we
take care of business models via the
topic of engineering feedback  Services,
the topic of assistance systems and
additive manufacturing includes seven
different technologies, both of which we
consider in an integrated manner, and on the right
again the examples of the
area of ​​application
is applied and that's
actually where we
are now, so we've been in
the project for a year and a half now, we're halfway there,
the first demonstrators have been set up
and the companies should and want to
and actually use
everything, of course, then we'll go through it
I'd like to  once we carry out what
we are also developing technologies with individual examples there
and if
we follow such a product or such a
company through the history, i.e.
from the emergence, then we
always start with somehow in a company
in the business model the subject of
the business model, so we deal
with it how must  because a company
aligns itself at the various levels
we have it here now channels key
resources cost structure but also
customer relationships customer segments how do
I have to set up a company in order to be
able to implement biological transformation I’ll go back to the
example of materials I
suddenly want to buy materials from a
recycling company  these
suppliers are these companies have
not been taken as suppliers up to now
that I may have to
realign my company that is one of the
things we are
dealing with let's
follow the product further now
we're at the point where I
want to develop these products too  That
means we are now developing
products digitally, everything is no longer
necessarily always
drawn by hand and then
made into plaster casts, but we are
now developing digitally and one
of the elements that we just said
is the topic of
developing new products
In this development, materials also take into account
the sustainability of the
product, which is why we have the
example of digital twins and their
CO2 footprint, which means that we
think about the product and plan
where the product will end up in
life, but also what
environmental impact it will have during  of life
the product of will occur that
means we are dealing with three
topics on the one hand to give companies
a hand with implementation assistance
how you can develop biobized products in the future
example new
materials take into account new
structure and new ideas clearly I can
with the wings of one of
look at the bird but how I deal with that in
my IT system is the one
part at the bottom right we see the topic of
machining processes machining processes
is now from production that I
look at individual production processes and think about how I can make
them more sustainable or
also learn from nature an
example has to calculate
react faster to new environmental conditions
so and the third part below left is
just the digital twin of products
digital twins is I have a
product that is physically there and
I know one-to-one how it works  about this
product just how was it planned what
was the idea behind it we will be
happy to tell you again later in this station two
that means how do
I actually communicate from such
a physical product to the digital
world
now we have developed the product
we have  the production processes are also
simulated and planned now we go into
actual production what do
we do there we take care of how
production can heal itself
as an example we
brought a wound healing device with us we all know that we
have a wound we hurt
ourselves there is one  The process of healing
and then the hand is fine again so
the skin does it all by itself ne our
body knows how it works in
production it is usually still so that
we have to react centrally somehow and
someone has to look at the problem
that has to be a reaction  and then
we take care of how you can, uh, let
me say the production
parts yourself, that means if
a process disruption occurs there is a
classic example of where
our partners we
work with are actually the issue of supplier
problems suddenly falling individual
countries way there are no
longer materials that you worked with before or
that you built on, which means I
may have to redesign my production to
react to that, a very
nice example, even now in the context
of Corona, many
production facilities have switched from the production
of silk scarves to
production  masks,
you have to be able to reschedule things really quickly,
the production is
usually aligned there, but
very rigidly we plan this product
from start to finish
is the next sub-project and in
this context, still in
production, the topic is about it  self-
coordinating and optimizing bio-intelligently
that sounds relatively
complicated I had already shown the entrance
with the mushroom that means the forest
can do that, the trees can do that, birds
can do that, bees can do that, they can
communicate with each other without there being
a system that
says how  they should talk to each other
but it is a sophisticated system
of one-to-one communication and that is exactly what
we want to implement in production
every machine every single
element knows what it can do itself where it
is and that means they
really communicate one-to-one
with each other there is  a kind of
description a description of competence
competence profile of each machine
men can speak that too
we are happy to invite you to discuss that here at
station 2
and understand
the third that's a very, very
important topic for us too I've
already got over  Environmental impacts spoken
but also the social issue is the
issue of society the issue of people we
will never get to the point where people are
no longer relevant in production or
people are no longer relevant in the company,
quite the opposite, the
tasks may
change, but we will always be people
need what we can do but that we
can make the work easier for him
an example is the subject of
ergonomics lifting heavy things
complicated tasks make
recurring tasks and we take care
of how we
can better support people in production that
also means communication in the
Environment we have the example Kobold
a collaborative robot they are such
small robots that can then
practically help you to work next to you
hold things things that such a
small assistance system is still enough for
people at the core where we also take care of it
is the topic of intelligent
Strong support, so if someone
is at the Hannover Messe, maybe
we'll bring it back with us, we're
always happy to show it, unfortunately it's
not included today, but in the end it's
when I lift a heavy box,
this system automatically recognizes
that I'm  my back is overloaded as an
example and supports
the subject of sensors at this point we are
also working with the subject of AR, which means
providing information better
instead of me as a worker in
production having to go somewhere and
have to read everything again, I have
this information exactly in that  Frame
as I would like to see it directly with me
that's such a human-oriented or
human-centered topic
and now something very important I
said before you have to think about the product
how's it going because at the end of
life is the topic of recycling management
that's where we have the partnerberal
on board who take care of the issue of
returning white goods
washing machines but also cooking fats,
for example, and that is very important
to think about
how can I make this efficient,
so how do I make sure that
the right parts arrive, but also
those  good circular economy strategy can
still be implemented what do we do we have
now brought an example with us at the
top left of the container where
all the things arrive we have
installed a camera system and in the
automated image recognition you know
how full the containers are, what is in
there and  what else can I do with it
this is a very clear example and the
automotive industry components arrive
a vehicle arrives is
disassembled and I have to understand
that it is still worth disassembling which
component can I still
use again which component has
valuable material but also
dangerous materials in it and
I can create all this data digitally to just
optimize the recycling
there we come to the point at the bottom
right it says as few
old parts as possible should leave the recycling case
and be thermally recycled
chemical processes thermal processes
eat up an incredible amount of energy and are
not  good for the environment, that means we
also take care of how can I
make something directly biodegradable and also one hundred
percent biodegradable in the end,
also align the processes so that
now the point where I
would like to hand over to my colleague Linus Linus does
n’t either  he says exactly
what in detail on this topic
thank you so I would like to
focus on this style project again
where we produce biogenic materials
or in this case direct
polymer which we can then print in production
and we actually use it as a basis
Waste materials, that is, they can be
biological substances
but it
has material properties similar to those of plastic, which
we are familiar with at our age,
and then it goes through the process
of cultivation, of course, the waste
we have to get it out of the bacteria
and then process it somehow,
so in that case we granulate it and
do it  a filament out which we then press
on this printer, for example, which we
brought with us, or
use injection molding exactly as granules, for example,
then whatever product we
print with it, for example orthoses, has a
certain usage phase and then
the special nature of the material comes into play again
Game that is 100%
biodegradable is in the domestic compost
so within months in nature
completely decomposes into plastic dioxide
and water
and to sum it all up, I have
n’t just described the whole process of
how bacteria actually
form this polymer and how we
actually do it  actually
carry it out in the laboratory, we have a small
film
where it might become a
bit
clearer
if you cultivate bacteria like this in a laboratory like this,
you can’t
go directly on a large scale, i.e. a
large volume, but have to
start with a small volume first  and that
is now ten milliliters here in the case
where we
have a nutrient solution in such a small flask
that is practically sufficient for the bacteria
to grow here we have already spread the bacteria
on a Petri dish,
which then form such small
farts on this dish
and then
you basically carry out the process, that is to say
inoculating, by you sort of taking bacteria from
the shell, you take a
colony like that, and then transfer it
to our solution,
as I said, in the near solution, now
everything is all available nutrients
can use to grow
and
you then cultivate the whole thing in a so-called
incubator at 30 degrees and leave it
in this voucher and shake practically overnight
from the air above
the liquid is introduced into the liquid,
this is similar to that in the
aquarium, for example,
and if the process is running as it
should, the bacteria grow overnight
by dividing and form
a real cell density, so to speak, and then
we can get out of the smaller  Volume
going into an intermediate volume that is
now half a liter in this larger flask
and that's where we
changed the medium for the first time, so the
medium we're using now
really only contains salts,
electrolytes and the waste materials that we consider
as a source of plastic
In this case, food for the bacteria use
frying fat
and then the same process as with the
small flask again overnight in such
an incubator
where the whole culture is shaken and
the oxygen is introduced back into the medium
and then overnight
it forms the  Cells divide and the
cell density increases, so a really
milky liquid and that's
the right here you can see it in the
flask that's the one that we then
use to tap the actual
bioreactor that we use for the production
of our
plastic
you do the whole thing
in a vaccination piston
that is almost simply in the pump piston,
where we can pump it out of this piston into the
reactor
and then it is the bioreactor that
we now have on site in the laboratory at
Fraunhofer IPK in which we produce the polymer
and  here you can see how it is
pumped a bit through this pump hose into the reactor the
culture and thus we inoculate the reactor
beforehand is also in the reactor has
just seen us also medium and
then we add the fat at this point
so we  look here on the right
this bottle of fat with really old chip
fat in it what we
use as a plastic source for the
bacteria as food then we can
monitor different things during the process with different
probes we have the oxygen probe
that monitors how much oxygen what
you have already said the the  Bacteria
also need in the medium
is the air supply filter, the filter,
so to speak, the air that we pump into the reactor
to protect the bacteria
from other germs,
exactly then we measure the pH value, i.e.
whether our
medium is acidic or basic
and this is what it looks like  what we
can measure during a cultivation, so
several readings that tell us
what phase the bacteria are in right now, so are
they still growing or are they
already forming the plastic? that happens to me
later in the process or are they
already in the scraping phase, so
basically no time  attitude
takes place more and we can see that on the basis of
these plots
these black triangles are the
dry substance, i.e. the actual cell
mass, which we then have out of cells
and it increases throughout the
cultivation and our goal is
to have as high a cell substance as possible at the end
of  now here about 55 grams per liter
and this is what the reactor looks like for
about 30 hours, so you can see
there is a correct cell density because it
is a very milky, cloudy liquid
and in order to create these plots that I
have just shown, we always have to in
between in the  Take samples during the process and
you simply take
a syringe, so to speak, which is on top of the reactor
and in the samples, which are then
processed further,
and we want to separate the cells that are now
all swimming around in the medium
from the medium and only the cells as a
pellet  and for this the whole thing is
centrifuged once,
for which we then transfer it to the
sample tube centrifugation and
then there are two more washing steps
to simply get out any medium that
is still in the solution
that in the end we just
have this cell pellet at the bottom
and that is that  then, as it were, our cells in
the inside of the polymer is what we
can then squeeze out
exactly the whole thing is dried to get all the
water out of it and then there is
an exaction step
after which we then have the finished PHB
which we then put in another
procession ship on the  Printer
can bring
exactly this is how it looks dried
and then after the extraction
so sorry during the whole
cultivation is you can actually
see how the cells of the PHB are really
growing so the cells at the
beginning of a cultivation look like simple
cell bodies relatively empty and at the end of the
Cultivation they have formed this polymer
and really in such a large
accumulation that almost fills the entire
cell body
then we harvest the whole thing
by simply pumping it out of the reactor
and then at the end after the
extraction from the cells we have our PHP
ready I have  since
we also brought it with us again, we can
look at it directly on the demonstrator, so we make granules
out of it, which we can then print
or filament exactly depending on which
application so in a printer the
filament is pressed, we make filament
here we see one now  um from
our partner company ARBURG the
printing granules
exactly what we then also produce from the polymer
what what the cells gain and
then print all possible shapes
with it,
be it orthoses or the example
of the French fries fork that
is personalized to the fingers
exactly what we  So far, the
test specimens that have been able to print quite well are simply
tension rods with which we can test the material,
i.e. what
temperatures can the material withstand, how
tear-resistant is it and so on and then
the application in the orthosis, for
example, exactly,
thank you very much, then I would
hand it back to
Teresa  Thank you
very much for the one look, so I
brought it here again, now at a
glance, we have learned, so to speak,
how companies have to align themselves
so that they can implement how logical
transformation
can start with themselves
once through this path from the
development of the products to
production  up to and including what does it look like
at the end of life and if I'm
still very exciting with this thought,
we
really went to Prahl in this project at this
residue depot took cooking fats
and you can imagine these cooking fats
that come from canteens
are actually deep-frying fats
but can also be food or
fats from production as waste,
i.e. lubricating greases, oil or
whatever and we did this process
was that was the video we just
saw prepared in such a way that you
can 3D print something on it why do
we do it  that in the research project because the
whole thing is not yet scalable, so I
couldn’t say right now I
kind of push out 100 cars a day
we’re not that far yet that’s still a
research process
to align these processes at all and
we also have a really big example
a bit brought along as a question is
in the room today
how do I recognize if I
have a product at home that it should
n’t put in the plastic waste that’s
actually a really big problem there
are many developed plastic foils
3D printed products but if
this orthosis is now  lying at home in the
kitchen you wouldn't be
able to see or know that that does
n't get into plastics that means
even the bio-based materials
if these days are still often burned
that also means a simply a
huge task of I'd say  of the
entire economy, the entire system,
but also of us as individuals,
to understand what
cycle means at the point
on the left, I said again everything
ecologically sustainable, that means we
do this sustainability assessment,
an ecological balance sheet, we also look
at what changes from the individual technologies
then before and after
because every digital product or every
infrastructure
IT system that we build also consumes
energy, so we can use all these
examples from Netflix as an example
Bitcoin or something like that, that’s all super
nice new ideas or blockchain the
topic of decentralization but needs everything
Energy and we try
to look at that is of course also one of
our tasks and it is not so
easy to always look in and
understand what is it for you, these are the
environmental effects
and now we have given a lot of input,
maybe all over again  In short, there are
questions at that point,
I mean, we're not such a big
group, so we're very
happy to just ask, I would
still bring the microphone
if it's okay, just so that the
rest of the audience can understand it
you bring it from behind
so my question would have been how is it
scalable you have already answered it is
not possible yet but what are the
obstacles so what does it take for
exactly what we just saw
and that the film was great we have
I think  everyone understood how it works
but what are the obstacles the
challenge the
challenges are twofold
one is to optimize the process so
that it works on a large scale
so what I do in the lab
on a two liter or 5 liter scale
works very differently on that
Production process where I have 1000 liters in
a reactor because in such a
bio-reactor there are inhomogeneities the
larger they get there is
not the same oxygen everywhere there
are not the same
nutrients everywhere and that is why my
process is completely different, that is to say, it starts to run in
The problem is this is
to abolish this scale from my research in the
laboratory to then really a
production process where I get a lot out of it
that I can really use,
so now this process that I
showed in this 2 liter reactor
which I ended up with 35 grams of plastic out of
I can even do that, that's enough for an
orthosis, but the Masters that's
one thing and the second thing is
to make the process cheap so that it's
also worthwhile economically, on
the one hand, of course, by
optimizing the process management, but
on the other hand, by using inexpensive substrates
and there is on the one hand waste fat
a good a very good solution because it is
relatively cheap or anything else
that you can imagine as waste,
so there are also processes that
work on cellulose, which you can use as
waste from agriculture and
fist economy, for example
those are two adjustment screws that
you have to turn, I would say, to
supplement the optimization exactly what
do we need to know and understand on the one hand
which materials are there
where so very practical question
collecting then there is
the whole process of
preparation and  production that
means that's why we also have the two
companies that
take care of this technology, that means we're
researching it before we build the
demonstrators and the prototypes, but at
some point
in the chain you need companies that
provide that is actually
one  good task for us as a German
medium-sized very very strong
economy actually there to
develop production processes
to provide the machines because at the
point hapaz of course that also means
the whole process of
collecting materials and preparing them then
printing and then of course the rethinking
in the companies that do that
doing things differently now, as long as plastic, i.e.
normal plastics, are cheaper to
buy, that's of course
a problem if the
pressure isn't there yet, yes, it's also
a political question, of course, in the
task of two things, so how much do
companies do how much do they do
Innovation and how much is also
required to prove, for example
if I don't know plastics or
other materials are somehow documented,
something like a CO2 tax as a
term now thrown into the room
that answers the question first of all there are more
I had two more  Questions about the oil
itself, so oil
actually floated on top, so you have to
work a lot more emulsifiers so that
it gets in there at all, or how do
you get it so that they
can metabolize it, so to speak,
and the other thing, fry fat,
everyone knows that  Soil has
it in there for a week actually
you should probably change it twice a day
what influence does that have because
everyone probably uses the fat for frying
differently and how
homogeneous is what the bacteria
do, so I add the oil
to the aqueous solution quite normally  and then
it is more or less dispersed by turning the
stirrer in the reactor,
so we have small
drops of oil, we don’t take any healthy um,
the bacteria express themselves, so
enzymes that they release lipases form,
so to speak, break down the fats into
individual fatty acids that the bacteria
can then absorb  so the
actual process of splitting
itself is taken over but outside the
cell and the bacteria then
absorb
what you actually see what
makes the difference what is in the frying fat
or so if it is now, for example,
not just but I don't know
send wings  or so then
of course there are other nutrients
because there are a lot more proteins
in there from the meat dissolved in the fat itself,
which then triggers a different
growth behavior in the
bacteria.
Ultimately, the project is the process
of forming the polymer, but
it’s pretty robust  Bacteria can
actually grow very well on most cases,
these are then marginal
differences, but you can definitely see an effect
what was in the fat before. Are there any
other questions?
I have a very practical question, what
do I do with such an orthosis when I put
it  then shouldn’t put it in the plastic waste
so and above all how do
I manage to do it afterwards that from the
whole thing really a cycle done
so to the materials
can come back again and again
so ultimately this PHB what we
print for really turns
into plastic dioxide and water in the end  these are
the end products what
naturally happens first is that it
breaks at some point and so I
know the word used in Hungary but
microplastic forms but in contrast to
what I’m saying now from PET
then it really breaks down
and  there are degradation processes that are
carried out by bacteria, for example, or also fungi in nature, so there
are also a room expressed that
then simply um the polymer splits
and in the end really in the balance
plastic dioxide and water remains
further questions
and what for  a bacterium
you use it is so genetically practically
modified so that it does what
we are now taking not that is called
Toner eutropha so it had had
several names in recent years the
currently even
of which there are also genetically
modified versions of strains which then a
other polymers form the mere
PHB that the wild type forms, which is
relatively difficult to process,
so you have to look a bit very
carefully at the pressure parameters and
also add additives, for example,
but there are actually modified strains
different polymer
form what a copular is made of so has a
slightly different chemical
composition which then actually
influences the pain temperature or the stiffness of the material
ok thanks and would i mean the
bacterium is production produced
would it die at some point because
it produces the polymer itself or
no, that would just
stop showing real activity at some point,
so it's kind of like the bacteria grows
like we grow fat for
energy storage and at some point kind of like at
a certain point in the process,
bacteria would start again
when there was no other food
left, that again  to break it down exactly
or do you always have to
take the samples for that um we always take
samples the stupid thing is
we can’t measure the optical density because we
have the fat in the reactor and that’s exactly
why the light refraction is different, that’s
why we take the offline samples
thank you very much
[music] suggest
it again
[music]
hit the shop now to make the
whole thing a bit more concrete to
put it deeper and to
show examples very briefly we have two
stations on the right-hand side is
exactly this chain that we just saw
have thought through the example
if the materials are there if the
other fabrics are there Linus can then
show it and we came up with it for a short time
if that would be
combined with this challenge as I said
have an individual product that
is station 1 so the question is how
can  we then change or transform waste into a 3D
printed product
and the second station
that we brought with us is the question of
how machines
or products actually use the Internet we have
said this quite often this communication if
machines have to communicate with you
they also need a medium  Minutes
and er, we displayed that on the page,
that is, how does the digital world react when
something changes in the physical world,
that is, because
we are not that many people, I would
suggest we just invite them in, let’s catch up
at the station
and then we still have time until 11
a.m. there was a lot of time to
answer questions once
I would just ask if you are
interested come to the
stations we may have
Sebastian get up on the
side Sebastian and  Wick so disst
station will be in English speakers week
is English speaking
out translate in German does not problem
so how does the machine or product you
the internet you can join week and
Sebastian and the grand the order
questions on the right we have the first
station  the first station on the subject of 3D
printing based on waste,
we have Linus, we also have Erik with us and
Louis, who are also very happy to
answer questions about it, that means come down
short as the
camera
very short question that will be
recorded we will now go
through the station on the right and through the
station on the left should we have
somehow thought about it anyway
you can also do it with a microphone once you can see it
on the camera  or is it
just that we're super here now,
then I'll just start on the right
and then
we'll do it all at the same time
so that we've also recorded the whole thing,
that means
I would go to the
first station here Linus will guide us
through Linus here  you a microphone
also there
go through the process again
and record but you make question
fits so
maybe someone scan right away
I would say if we we start
with the process here on the right who
hadn't scanned their hand yet
look here in  the round
please we already have a volunteer
person right here wins the whole
process Linus does the whole thing once
exactly
what we do first is to scan the hand
to create a 3D model from
which the orthosis
can be adapted I would like to have one here
you can  hold the things then it got
a bit over
[music]
so we
brought the orthosis as an example orthosis because it's
actually used in production
it's just an example there
are, as I said, a lot of materials
and parts that you  can use or
products in order to customize a 3D print into the
workpiece, but in the hand it is of course
also very individual and that is why
we have chosen this example for today
to say that the length,
width, finger
diameter varies greatly  Exactly
and um, in order to adapt the orthosis personally,
we have to create a 3D
model of the hand, which we
do here with this hand-held scanner,
right there, just put your hand on the
markings,
it doesn't have to be exactly in your fingers,
then you can do it now  see on the
screen how the model
is created 3D model by hand
you can now imagine as an example
for other parts as I said what
broke I want a
spare part I have a special
workpiece holder that you could also
scan and create yourself on it now
just this model,
we can use different ones or we
have now brought two production processes with us,
one is the orthosis,
which we have often spoken about,
I also have two with me for the material
and the other, which we
have as a bit of an example and the
whole thing
To round off the story that we use frying fat
is actually a
personalized French fries fork which we also
adapt to the finger
the basic processes are the same,
whether we now adapt an orthosis to the
finger or our fork
adapts a finger we have a quasi 3D
model and can use it to
Decreasing the diameter of the individual fingers, so to speak, that's
exactly what we're going to transfer the
model to the other
station, where there's already a
segmentation, folks, I'd maybe
just switch there, then
we'll save ourselves the steps of
transferring exactly what will be there, so to speak,
that you have a 3D model  loaded in and
then the fingers are segmented
and we choose one in the
optimal club that has been scanned well
or hold it erm if we scan a bit
longer it works
with all fingers where we
then need the orthosis, so now in this case you
you have an orthosis right on the
middle finger and then we take
off three diameters maybe you can
scroll with this one
exactly so we take one
behind the back behind the
middle joint of the finger then on the
middle joint and in front of the middle joint
those are those  Points, so to speak, that we
need to optimize the model,
which means you also had to
think beforehand about whatever
parameters you want to scan and what parameters you
want to read out, so I don’t know
if I took my whole arm now, of
course you could do that too
use for medical purposes,
so all of this is somehow familiar with a
cruciate ligament tear and I somehow need
a
support system here, which means you
could scan every type of body but also
every part, I have to
think beforehand which parameters I read
out and that's called a
parameterized 3D  Model that I
automatically scale and adjust the model,
so you could use it for different
applications, in this case
just for the topic of orthosis,
basically as Theresa already said,
so the individual fingers are approximated from the palm of the hand
and you first
First of all, cylinders are formed and these are then
brought closer and closer to the scanning
and this scan is then divided into
different
layers as you have now
seen and based on
the principle of what this component
is actually supposed to do is this one
Generation
to generate the model for printing
then adapted, so in our case,
of course, the joint should
be supported, that's why we have a
measuring point on the joint and of course
we want to have the largest possible
support area to keep the finger
stiff, so we
then make the widest points
the next joints,
so then in front of the second or in front of the one
directly on the hand exactly and based
on what we then selected there,
we can then generate the model
and the algorithm then overwrites that
into a model which we
can then print
exactly that  it takes a little while until the model
is adjusted in the background or by the program
I would perhaps use the time and
briefly present the materials that we
have just seen in the video again
I can do it again to everyone
I would just
walk around with you right away exactly that sort of that
Powder how we get it out of the bacteria,
so the PHB let me say
in its row form,
really a white powder
what we got out of the bacteria,
how is that going to win is that we
sort of crush the bacteria in the
homogenizer and then separate the polymer
from the rest  of the cells
then the next step is
to bring the inner filament to explode, so to speak,
and to help with this, the
powder is simply compressed in an extruder, i.e. a machine specially designed for this purpose,
and then a strand is
pressed
and then I had already said that
this ferment can  we were already
squeezing on the printer
the printer that you saw from the video
were granulate printers,
basically the filament is
simply chopped into the granulate, which
the printer can then use or
an injection molding machine, for
example, so it is then for several
applications  possible
exactly then we already had an orthosis here before
we had I think
printed I don't know where it went I don't know where it
went it was a more complex kind of
like a french fork that
Erik Fringer scanned exactly that
now fits Erik Finger
and then have it  we already talked about the
application at Mercedes-Benz,
they have an accident where they have to
keep
making a pressing movement in the component, i.e. where
components are pushed in and
to support the worker, we
developed this orthosis  basically
has a protection on the thumb here at the front and
then this joint at the back, which
prevents the joint from being pushed through,
which was not
adapted to my thumb either, so it sits
a bit loosely, but
that's exactly what I'll say at the end when
I'm demonstrating  in our project
it is definitely
in use then exactly that is also
actually used at Mercedes Benz
here we have a great many
assembly steps so right now the
changeover to electromobility, for example,
means that
a lot of cables are assembled, for example,
so a huge thing  is when
pushing the cable somewhere in electric vehicles, things are pinching things
in this electrical area and one topic
is then also show me to check whether
something is already correctly clicked in and
you can hear that, so we
humans can do it quite easily ne
if I feel it  Resistance I
always notice when someone tells me that the IKEA
instructions click in until there is
an XY tone. We humans
can hear it, we can feel it,
the thing is, machines aren’t
so good at it. We showed that earlier in
the topic Kobold  So a robot
can't feel it that well and we're
trying to research that in different
elements
also
really notice how many cables
were clicked in or the
assembly step is finished because when the
robot is waiting to take the next
step, it has to be
informed somehow and that's just
one possibility that such an
orthosis then, for example, with the
next machine or  communicated the next
step
so I had one more question now that
we are standing together because we
thought about it a bit we
of course come from production we have
all these examples oh orthosis then
this from a chip fat
to a french fries fork that we
thought of  has a few other
ideas, but we wanted to
pass this on to my room now, whether you might have something from
your private environment,
wherever you work, your context,
whether you have ideas for products that
we can print for you in the future that are
actually biodegradable
should or could, so if you can
think of something, I would like to invite Linus to the
discussion and I don't know
whether you are leading this discussion with Linus because
then I wouldn't even go over there and
communicate I had
just asked the question about the products
what that  is there still something that you
might use privately
that actually consumes my visitors that it
is automatically
connected to each other right now or is that no, that’s why it’s
okay
I’ll just join in I
didn’t want to interrupt now I always talk
with the microphone so that it’s just recorded
actually a big
topic so especially with this
aspect I would like to let a machine or
product do the talking
communicate that of course I
always I always need the internet I need
the infrastructure I have to think about the fact
that it is often sensitive data so
we work together with Mercedes Benz
where  we actually record the energy data from
production, of
course, a lot of information can also be
read out, such as how quickly the product was
produced, quality data, this is
incredibly sensitive data for companies,
which of course they don’t
want or don’t want to give out if you don’t
know where the information goes,
as well as the topic of energy consumption
Of course you can give it out as a CO2 backpack
or CO2 footprint producam, however,
above all as a product in the
sense of up to now I am selling this
vehicle and what has
happened so far, nevertheless this
look at the individual products is
super individual and very useful for the
company  very secret that means
really right that means you have to
deal with a lot of IT infrastructure things so how do
I make sure how do I make sure that
this communication from there to there
nobody can intercept where is this
data stored digitally hosted
evaluated just this  The subject of
evaluation again means I need
different elements that
talk to each other exactly.
Calculating the CO2 footprint means I
have to evaluate it, so just because I know
how much electricity is produced here and there does
not mean that I know what
the environmental impact of the product
is  there is also a translation
that you have to do on the spot and
that means you need different
databases and solutions that talk to each other
and that's for companies, especially
when we have to talk or
medium-sized companies, that's a huge
question, how do I make sure
my data is safe that I am
still somehow protected with my company
and I am not vulnerable
and can still provide the information
because they will
have to put it in quotation marks in the future,
so the world is moving, which means
I would like to know this footprint for a product
in the future, that means  all
elements in the supply chain also have
their own it
's not right so
it has to be the one question but this
process has to be initiated to
prepare for it how could I do that,
what data do I have to collect for this,
but also what safety precautions
do I have to take, for example  do what does
the calculation logic look like exactly
these topics this is such a huge
communication
awareness transformation process
especially for small medium-sized companies that is
why we have also brought two examples
here once this open
source solution has open sources
everyone can simply use it it costs nothing
it of course has this  The challenge is
that maybe I don't know where
my data is, so
I don't have these security elements if I do
n't operate it myself and have a
process on the other side together
with the partner
context software exactly that a
company right they have they
simply have in their portfolio
software that takes care of
product data management as well as the
iot platform, i.e. processes the data from
the Internet and
operates this platform, which individualizes
that but of course also ensures
other things such as the secure
exchange of data, as an example
we are  brought both times because we also
want to show it is feasible with a
bit of skills and knowledge
of, let's say, the digital world, but it
's not that easy, so it's
not quite like I'm really pressing the button
like I do with a
website these days
and of course it is also an issue that
we have to train the people, the engineers,
the people for tomorrow
what sustainability means for
me, what does digitization mean for
me and what does e.g. digital
twin or all this
sensor technology ioti mean, what does it have for my
employees  for an impact that
is also a very big training aspect
that is of course behind
this profile of someone who
can do data science or data engineering who
can do software development and the
mechanical engineer bauerinus so
basically an engineer that
doesn’t exist yet if the person then also
sustainability  must take into account
a lot comes together
comes right and that is one of the
big main tasks exactly
really
I'm
very nice we're looking forward to
breaking it down and that's such a
big topic so when we
talk about circular economy
we always talk about these new
strategies  So
Reviews recycle recover there are so many
that you have to break down first,
we wanted to do that too with a
tangible example, so now the
orthosis, so this example, we
take waste fat from here and I
could now decompose this orthosis myself,
on the compost, to put it very
rudely  put it on the compost and
I wouldn't have to worry about it but also
make it clear as I said if I
had this orthosis at home I would
probably throw it in the um in the
yellow sack because I would think
oh this has to be recycled
right and these are  so the follow-up team that we are
now considering how can you
recognize that, so you do that with
certain non-visible fabrics,
you have to put a print on it somehow,
so that you say there is
somehow a certain label on every material or product,
such as the
deposit return symbol  but of course you have to
play along with the whole economy so that's a
good question BSR bral is
actually a subsidiary of
BSR and that means they only take care
of a certain part, so
BSR also makes household waste and
exactly and also deals with
the topic of
recycling  but old bulky
waste bulky household waste and swarms
and exactly this topic electrical parts
and food waste and so on
you have at bral that means it is of
course also formed like this collection points
general comes exactly from this from
this area yeah um and that’s exactly
where it should of course happen
So you can't say to each individual
person please
separate everything so I don't know, um,
acquaintances of mine work at the BSR
and they told me at some point you
can collect corks, so corks from bottles
should be collected separately because they
are worth so much and they have them  there is
also a separate collection point on the farms
but you don’t know that as an
end customer at first as a
private person
yes I’m really happy to get a
card right away
but we really like to do it
is always bring it with you always
talk and understand asking questions
where comes  come on
if that suits you I'll
explain right away
okay since it's still running in parallel
I would just tell it through what we
brought with us we have a
one station in the station
it's about understanding how can
products or machines with  communicate on the internet
that means we look
at just keep doing it you can
[music]
so we look at how machines
or products can communicate with the internet
and one of these
topics is of course I have to be able to
send information about the product via sensors  e.g. where am I at
the moment classic question, especially in
production that is super exciting because
I always don’t maybe not know where
the individual materials the individual
products are at the moment where is
somehow I don’t know the one
robot that’s the question but also for
me privately we  everyone knows that our
mobile phones have the where am I function that
I think has always been important to all of us
and these are basic
elements that you don’t even
notice anymore that already exist but of
course you can also use them very specifically
and in  In our context,
we not only look at where is the product
or where is it how is it
doing, but also what kind of
environmental impact this product has,
that means how much energy
it is consuming right now, but also how much
energy has been generated in the
Production phase all the materials that
we order were procured somewhere at some
point there was heat at some point there
was sometimes cold at some point there was
transport at some point, so
transport and logistics in particular have an
incredible impact on the
total sum of what a product does with the
environment and what is  so for
influences that means these these
topics you can look at all of them
but it is quite often that the topic of
life cycle assessment uses average data
that means databases there
you can imagine I look at
a uh I don’t know it needs a ton of steel
on average XY  of CO2 on
average, but that doesn't mean that
for my company and for my
product, let's take the mobile phone again,
of course, this value
has accrued because perhaps it was
sent on it was taken by plane it was
flown by plane
it was flown on a
container ship  all of this has
an immense influence on my
individual product and that is why
this term I call it
digital twin comes into play
digital twin means I do
n’t just look at the average value
as the information that we all now
as end consumers are in right now
Average values ​​have often come up, but I
know that actually for my vehicle,
which is right now on my doorstep,
maybe also in the sharing context,
ne, that I
have the most accurate data possible for this vehicle and also
know, okay, that was really
produced in Poland, that was in  I do
n't know made in India it was
then transported here by plane
and it's super
individual and this is where
the digital twin comes in.
I need two elements because one
is when I tell you now that there were 50
kilowatt hours that were incurred  are
then that's a value but I have
no comparison I don't know is
it good or bad that means I have to
understand on the one hand what
the engineers
may or should have thought at the beginning
how much do I need at least and I
may I  need as much as possible that means I
always need the plan value compared
to how things are currently going, also
things like lifespan
we are all interested in our products as well
how long will it live when will it
break and there is usually a
calculated duration lifespan and  this
is usually linked to the fact that I
say, for example, mileage,
i.e. how many kilometers the
vehicle should drive how many operating hours does
my cell phone have if I never turn it on then
it will last longer that is quite
clear that we all know but
we actually have these  Information
not via she the Lina because
any database in any
systems at the companies who
think about it and that's where
we start that means at the point
to network this actually planned data
with yes and now the
product has arrived in the recycling for how
long  did it actually live how
many kilometers did it actually
do or how many operating hours
did it actually have and if I
combine that and I love a lot of
products and keep
noticing that there are always ten what I don't mean
10,000 operating hours less then
I can get away with it  learn and say at the latest
for the next product generation I'll do
it better in the best case but
maybe already for the now that means I
say I'll replace a part
that's called proactive maintenance that
means not only when something breaks
but I know when I do  If I were to
replace the engine and the transmission, then
I would have the option of the
entire vehicle living longer, so one of the
places where the digital twin comes in is that
I first have to be able
to have my product
communicate with me, wherever it is, as I said, we are
all used to that  from a mobile phone that
's nothing new for us anymore is
for a production
production unit a machine but that's
not so self-evident
because I can perhaps say where
it is at the moment but how many products have
already been produced or how much
energy has it used that is
not so easy at all and that's why we have
Sebastian and Vicky, for example, here
my switch in English so that was what
Sebastian develops
everything is in the production facility
at a total place is where you have
the analytics that reaction
and the production is in Berlin
all  the information
okay so sorry my we know
so would talking about how this is
connected to the use that we the we
should earliars of course for the
pressure sensitive
because exactly
somebody using this is too boah pizza
train
is pressing to high this too much
pressure on  the fun
a break on the end
of the use
can use the
waters on wante
moistinitys ORF
sleeking of something like that
was your question
connected in anyways to this is
communicating wellness where the wifi in
which we have the internet with the platform
in all the data is  ist dort there and
soft quest this is just the first Depp
and Teresa was saying ear so we got from
just the communication to addition
system which looks for every machine
every product a production process how
much NSY is consumed at the moment and
you card calated for  each product you
can imagine also the time Willers no
nothing for does still accounts to this
one product the same for you lights on
but you not working it's the part of
your footprint in this our that you
there this production have to shutdown
the machine
have too  think about like how much
speedric
Consum this basically producing as much
itwith
impactory can
intelligence system to analizer
understand
all one questions now we should your
the boss station since thank you're
summer you have maybe easy you princet or
this is the take home and this theme
Assembly work at home
and we should you there machinery or
product communication with the internet
do you have an questions Force ideas
Feedback
okay
Transformation means and the fut join
Frauenhofer and beer resear Camper
happy for any this gun and Coloration so
thank you thank you the team  is well and
to the rest of the team